it's been more than a decade since fans
got to sit in the theater and watch
Robert Downey Jr in Jude Law hunt
criminals through the back alleys of
London and Guy Richie's Sherlock Holmes
franchise but will the game as they say
ever be afoot once more even before
Sherlock Holmes a game of shadows hit
theaters a third movie in the series was
announced with writer Drew Pierce who
was then prepping Iron Man 3 for Marvel
hired to pen the script though no
release date was revealed it wasn't
expected to be far away but scheduling
soon became a major obstacle in
September 2012 Jude Law remarked on
these delays telling collider I mean
there's certainly talk of it and I know
there's a script being played around
with but Downey's a busy boy and I'm a
busy boy so we'll see but we want to do
another one we are a very happy team and
we have a lot of fun and we also think
there's still a lot of legs in the duo
between Robert Downey Jr Jude Law and
director guy Richie always being in
demand it seems like something had to
give if Sherlock Holmes 3 were to ever
move forward that give finally gave in
2019 when Dexter fled signed on to
replace Richie as the sequel's Director
with a planned 2021 release date but
when the kova 19 pandemic hit in 2020
the project became one of many to be put
on hold as of 2022 Fletcher remained
unsure of when Sherlock Holmes 3 might
finally see the light of day telling
collider I don't know what the timeline
of that is unfortunately but I believe
it should be happening it's fantastic I
think it's about all the right people
being at the right place at the right
time I think it's that the cast of the
first two Sherlock Holmes movies have
had a lot to say about the prospect of a
follow-up starting with the man who
directed the first film guy Richie in
2022 he spoke with collider about the
long gestating third entry and said it
all depends on the movie star remarking
so Robert Downey Jr wanted to be in
charge of this the ball's in his court
so he's in charge of the script he's in
charge of the whole thing I've Moon
locked out of that until there's a time
for me to get involved he'll no longer
be party to my investigations he's out
of the equation considering the Downey
has become one of the most powerful
stars in Hollywood the last 10 years it
can be assumed that he could use his
clout to take charge of Sherlock Holmes
3. so what has he had to say about it so
far the actor has been tight-lit but his
Entourage spoke to the rap in 2023 with
an encouraging update Downey's wife and
producing partner Susan Downey explained
we had lunch together with Robert the
three of us and Sherlock Holmes 3 was a
very specific topic of conversation so
yes it's in the hopper we're going to do
it when it's right with the right people
but it is a priority for the company and
a priority for Robert
if Sherlock Holmes 3 ever does come to
pass what will it be about the finale of
Sherlock Holmes a game of shadow sees
the end of Holmes's Nemesis Moriarty as
well as the fake out death of Holmes
himself who returns in the film's
closing moments the third entry could
pick up right where that scene leaves
off but with more than a decade having
passed since the second film debuted
that might not be possible what we do
know is that Robert Downey Jr has big
Ambitions for the threequel in a 2014
Reddit AMA he said we have a Sherlock 3
in development we want it to be the best
of the series so that's a pretty tall
order
though some might scoff at a return from
Moriarty the long layoff could come in
handy here the villains returned from
Death whether through a literal
Resurrection or his own crafty fake out
could provide star power from actor
Jared Harris and a worthy adversary
looking for a long-awaited rematch
against the London Detective
conclusion inevitable whether the film
reintroduces Holmes's most famous foe
adapts a classic literary tale we've yet
to see on screen or creates an entirely
new enemy for homes to face everyone
involved wants to make sure it's a story
worthy of a third fill Jude Law told
Empire we want it to be better than the
other two we want to make sure it's
smarter and cleverer but in the same
Realm
the world of movies has changed a great
deal since the first Sherlock Holmes
film set theaters all the way back in
2009 between the explosion of cinematic
universes and the rise of streaming
platforms like Netflix and Amazon Prime
video it's harder and harder for new
movies to make their Mark and find
success throw in the devastating impact
of the kova 19 pandemic on the entire
theater industry around the world and
there's no telling what kind of a box
office Sherlock Holmes 3 would net
moreover Arthur Conan Doyle's Sherlock
Holmes stories have garnered a number of
popular adaptations since 2009. most
prominent is the BBC's Sherlock series
starring Downey's MCU co-star Benedict
Cumberbatch the show which debuted in
2010 quickly became one of the hottest
series on television for many modern
viewers cumberbatch's Sherlock is the
definitive on-screen take on the
character Stateside cbs's Elementary
enjoyed a wildly successful seven
seasons on the air led by Johnny Lee
Miller as Sherlock and Lucy Liu as Dr
Joan Watson moreover Netflix netted a
major hit with Enola homes Henry Cavill
plays the famed detective in this film
which got a sequel in 2022
that's not where the adaptations end
either recall the notorious 2018 flop
that is Holmes in Watson there's also
the 2015 drama Mr Holmes starring Ian
McKellen is an aging version of Sherlock
finally there is the upcoming CBS series
Watson which is of course centered
around Holmes's right-hand man have
audiences had their fill of Arthur Conan
Doyle's great sleuth it's possible that
Sherlock Holmes 3 might simply be a bit
too much Sherlock in an already Sherlock
heavy time
[Music]
foreign